this is a production of Cornell
University so I'll start by demystifying
the title a little bit I won't reread it
to you since Michael just read it but
essentially what this means is that
there are individuals of Aspergillus
fathers who produce aflatoxin and
individuals that do not and both are
maintained through evolutionary time
which means that producing alpha toxin
must confer a benefit to the fungus
sometimes and not producing the toxin
must confer benefit at other times so
I'm gonna just give you a little outline
I'm going to start with some background
on secondary metabolites in general
moving into background on Aspergillus
flavus and aflatoxins talk a little bit
about work we've done and looking at a
flautist population structure talk about
the hypotheses behind that we think
might be driving balancing selection and
spoiler alert it's we think it's insects
and soil microbes and then concluding so
secondary metabolites are generally
defined as just any compound that's not
required for growth and interestingly in
fungi there have been hugely diversified
and this is partially due to the
diversification of poly q tide
synthetases
and non-ribosomal peptide among peptides
impetuses most other things but just
because we know of all these compounds
it doesn't mean that we know what they
do for the organisms that produce them
so for example here in magna portho
arise ii it was discovered that melanin
which we normally think of as a UV
protectant is also required in a purse
or 'ya for structural integrity so that
it can actually punch through plant
tissue so this to say even when we think
we know what compounds are for there may
be other functions or we may just be
wrong so to start off with some things
that we have a sense of what they do
these are host specific toxins which
determine the host range so you can
imagine if it produces one of these
compounds then it's able to infect a new
host and that obviously confers a
fitness advantage to the fungus so it
would be selected for and with virulence
factors virulence is not the same thing
necessarily as Fitness you can have
increased virulence without increased
Fitness but in general it does
correlate some degree so again it
suggests that we have a sense of what
these compounds are doing they're
allowing the fungus to infect a new
plant or to better infect a plant and
thus reproduce more but in the case of d
axing de balón all which is also
classified as a micro toxin it's known
as vomitoxin endearingly it's again the
way that we find out about these
compounds is because they are toxic
so actually we heard a little bit about
last week so I had to throw it up there
but I got alkaloids even back in the
15th century when Bush did this painting
you can see that Saint Anthony's fire
was an issue long before we knew that
there were microbes causing these
diseases we knew about the compounds
well we knew about the diseases they
caused and we've gone on to learn about
that but this is all from a human
perspective instead of what it does for
the fungus that produces the compound
and that's of course important because
micro toxins contaminate 25% of the
world's food supplies and they cause
disease and stunting of growth and even
death but again well that's sad and
costly to the to everyone involved in
agriculture what I want to know is why
do the organisms that produce these
compounds produce them just to drive
home that we really don't know what
these compounds do so we think about
antibiotics antibiotics if you ask
anyone what why does a bacterium produce
antibiotics they'll say to kill bacteria
or fungus proves antibiotics to kill
bacteria and we know that they're
effective at killing bacteria in the lab
and medical settings however in their
natural settings so like in soils the
levels of antibiotics are actually sub
inhibitory so the idea that they're
killing bacteria has kind of gone out
the window
as far as antibiotics in their natural
environment instead people now believe
that they're used for interest specific
communication in the soil environment so
this kind of brings home the idea that
we have to think about not what these
compounds are doing to us but what these
compounds are doing in the natural
environment at the concentrations and in
the context of the natural
ecology of the organisms that produce
them so now moving on to the star of the
show alpha toxin alpha toxin is an
incredibly important mycotoxin it is the
most carcinogenic naturally produced
compound which has been a great line for
my elevator speech when I'm talking
about my research it affects the p53
gene which regulates the cell cycle so
if it disrupts that then the cells
become aberrant and just grow out of
control it's especially associated with
liver cancer which is a particularly
nasty one as such is highly regulated by
the FDA in a bunch of crops including
maize cotton peanuts and a variety of
tree nuts today as you notice from the
title we're going to be looking at
Aspergillus flavus but is actually
produced a fluxes are produced by
several species closely related to
Aspergillus flavus
and here you can see estrogen alavés
growing on this ear of corn and you'll
notice that it's a yellowish green color
that's going to be important later I
want you to retain that and then this is
an infected kernel fluorescing a bright
blue so aflatoxin the one that we're
most interested is called b1 is it
fluoresce is blue so again the colonies
are a yellowish green it fluoresce is
blue and here we have Aspergillus flavus
growing on a plate and we're hitting it
with UV light and it's illuminating the
red is just at overloading the system
but what you can see here is that
different isolates produce different
amounts so these two are not producing
any this one is producing these two are
producing a little he's reducing more
and these two are producing just a lot
of aflatoxin
and what this illustrates is that only
40 to 60% of Aspergillus flavus isolates
produce aflatoxin and that people have
looked at the genetic code so this
happens across the country forty to
sixty percent all over the place but
also if you look at the genetic code you
find evidence of balancing selection
which means that this is a persistent
polymorphism again it means that at some
point athletes producing alpha toxin
confers of
this advantage at some point not
producing apple toxin confers a fitness
advantage relative at least to the other
chemo type so this is we're really
interested in this balancing selection
it's important to note that while
balancing selection is rare for
secondary metabolites as far as we know
it's not unique so track of species and
Fusarium Grumman arum are also under
balancing selection but even here this
is a little bit different so this
balancing selection is for different
chemical profiles as opposed to produce
and not so this is kind of an
interesting system in addition to being
agriculturally important so my mantra
today or what are the ecological factors
that are driving balancing selection and
as I've been saying in order to get at
this question we have to look at the
natural ecology of the fungus so the
fungus the natural environment of the
fungus is typically considered soil
where it produces Canadia four's that
disperse spores everywhere and I really
do mean everywhere it has a global
distribution and because of this spores
being distributed everywhere it can get
into crops while they're in the field in
maize it infects the silk it grows
through the silk and then gets into the
kernels but it can also be a post
harvest issue because it's just in the
air everywhere now if we're trying to
understand what aflatoxin is doing for
it we might expect aflatoxins only to be
sequestered in the sclerotia as like
overwintering structures to protect them
unfortunately we did not it didn't give
us any kind of sense of that is the
aflatoxins are everywhere in it it's in
the mycelium it's in the Canadia it's in
the sclerotia and also it's not as
clear-cut as just being a virulence
factor it's not like those that produce
alpha toxin can infect a plant and those
that don't can't so
no hints really on what aflatoxin is
doing but again is just to give some
background on what the natural ecology
is that we need to look at to understand
what athletes bison is doing so if it's
not if you can't just tell
what Athens doing by where it
sequester's it in the fungus itself
maybe there's global distribution
patterns that can kind of start to help
but to help us understand now aflatoxin
has been known to be more common in hot
dry areas for a long time but it's a
little unclear if this has to do with
the stress on the plant so this plant
gets stressed it's easier to infect you
wind up with more athlete oxygen
contamination or if this is just a
phenomenon where higher hotter
temperatures at lower latitudes select
for athletic so genic while the cooler
latitudes select for non athletics genic
and so when looking at soil here man
abhi
in 1978 showed that the black portion
here is athlete oxygen 'ok those that
produce aflatoxin as you can see he
showed that as you go farther and
farther south this portion is increasing
suggesting that at lower latitudes in
hotter areas there's more selection for
aflatoxin production so we decided to
follow up on this because japan is far
away we decided to do it in the united
states so we developed two transects so
these are roughly of the same latitude
here across and so we did sampling at
all of these locations with the help of
collaborators who scooped up soil and
sent it to us and then we isolated them
on soil dilutions plates so this is a
rose bengal plate and you can see the
yellowish green colonies here or
Aspergillus flavus coming up so we take
the soil we put it onto a plate and then
we can isolate it with a single Canadian
also these plates are just really
cool-looking so what do we find what we
find is we don't see the same pattern as
base on Japan forty years ago in the
eastern transect we don't see any real
pattern at all
it's there's a lower percentage of
aflatoxin producers goes higher it goes
lower if anything in the Western
transect it's going the opposite
direction where we're seeing more
aflatoxin producers towards the north
this to say there doesn't seem to really
be a clear pattern it's not as simple as
just in southern latitudes aflatoxin
production is favored so it's not
latitude than what Dan Jannsen who's an
evolutionary biologist currently at Penn
wrote a paper that suggested that
secondary metabolites in jenner general
and specifically aflatoxins may be an
agent of interference competition by
which you produce these chemicals into a
substrate and then you kind of claim the
substrate as yours
to consume because nobody else wants to
eat it because you've poisoned it
basically or interference can a
competition can also be that you the
compound just keeps down other species
so he specifically suggests that this
would be an agent of athletics one would
be an agent of interference competition
for insects and for soil microbes okay
so Dan Dan Jannsen suggested as an idea
let's follow this up with a real
hypothesis so we started off with the
hypothesis that aflatoxin production
confers an advantage to a flavius in the
presence of soil microbes again this
would be through interference
competition where production and soil
kind of carves out some resources for
Aspergillus flavus to grow and have
higher fitness and the flipside here is
that in the absence of these organisms
so in the absence of soil microbes or in
the absence of insects we kind of assume
a cost so the production of aflatoxin
takes energy so we just kind of assume a
cost so this to say while we're doing
balancing selection we're just doing one
side of it with these hypothesis right
now I'll come back to that later so
we're starting with soil microbes in
order to look at soil microbes we need
some of the background aflatoxins are
produced in soil which is a
first step if you're hypothesizing that
they have a role there and aflatoxin
contamination of soil is common both in
agriculture where farmers have to bury
really contaminated crops and the
aflatoxins leach into the soil but also
just because detritus on the soil
surface can leach aflatoxins into the
soil so people have found aflatoxins
leaching into the soil and also produced
in the soil
now aflatoxin does have limited toxicity
to microbes but in some studies it does
keep down some microbial communities and
interestingly bacillus and Aspergillus
flavus have this relationship where
bacillus produces compounds that are
very inhibitory to Aspergillus and
Aspergillus flavus
are produced apple toxin which has seems
to have the biggest effect on bacillus
species specifically of the microbes
that people have tested okay so to look
at whether or not a Fatah and production
confers a benefit in the soil
environment we took a falcon tube and we
put soil in the bottom of it now this
soil was either autoclaved or not
autoclaved we also tried gamma or
radiating it and it didn't the fungus
didn't grow any differently and
gamma-irradiated so from autoclaves and
autoclaving is a little bit easier so we
went with that and then we either in
some experiments we added toxin or we
did not add toxin to the soil itself and
that was both too sterile soil or non
sterile soils then of course we have to
add the fungus so we added a bunch of
isolates separately either nontoxigenic
or toxigenic isolates to these tubes
under these conditions and then we would
extract the DNA and use qpcr to quantify
the amount of DNA that was present and
so that's kind of a proxy for fitness so
the more DNA that's present the more
that it's growing the higher the fitness
and this will be important later my
graphs are going to say relative fitness
qPCR you quantify things relative to a
standard curve so relative fitness just
means a measurement relative to a curve
on here there you can just think of them
as fitness
numbers but it'll say relative fitness
we also looked at HPLC to quantify the
aflatoxins make sure it was producing
under some of our conditions and make
sure that our addition of aflatoxin
stayed actually happened and then for a
subset of the samples we did amplicon
sequencing to look at the microbial
communities and try to understand what
both the addition of aflatoxins and the
ability of the fungus to produce
aflatoxins what effect that had if any
on the microbial community so again to
show you this is what the microcosms
looked like so these are the falcon
tubes that I was talking about and this
is a close up inside so we added a
little bit of maize and here you can see
a maize bit with Aspergillus fathers
Canadia 4 is coming off of it this is
one of our non autoclaves so this would
be considered natural soil and you can
see here there's Penicillium species
coming up we often see a whole bunch of
different species that we haven't really
identified but i'll talk about some of
the composition in a minute so we did
this initially we looked at three
different temperatures so we had 25
natural and sterile 37 natural and
sterile and 42 natural and sterile and
what you immediately notice is that the
42 is a stressful condition even under
the sterile condition the growth is way
down but at 37 and 25 the growth is more
or less the same these are not
significantly different these in sterile
are significantly different but we're
interested in the question of what does
aflatoxin do for it not it does it grow
differently in the sterile or at
different temperatures we just this was
initially what we were doing because we
didn't know we were going to find so
we're like let's look at all the
temperatures and what we find is that in
the natural soil we consistently see
that the non-athlete oxygenic have
higher fitness than the alpha toxigenic
so not producing aflatoxin seems to
confer a benefit here and this is only
in the natural soils if you look at the
sterile soils if there's no clear pad
here the non-athlete oxygenic has a
little bit higher media mean here it's
the Alpha toxigenic here they're exactly
identical but across the natural soil is
there was a significant difference
between the non-athlete oxygenic and the
alpha toxigenic Fitness okay so this was
the opposite of what we expected we
expected aflatoxin to keep down other
soil microbes allowing it to colonize
more food and grow better so we didn't
believe this this is experiment one we
didn't really believe that this was a
real thing so we did it again and this
time we were like we're gonna hit it
with a ton of alpha toxin because that
way we'll definitely see the effect that
we were expecting so here we have a
different and independent set of
isolates grown again in natural and
sterile conditions natural and sterile
this time with the addition of alpha
toxin in these two and no aflatoxin
added here and with this independent
experiment that was at 37 so note that
the best growth was at 37 so it was
easiest to work with the fungus at that
temperature this is at 37 we see the
same pattern that a natural soil we see
a significant difference between
[Music]
non-athlete oxygenic and alpha toxigenic
isolates now it looks like the same
patterns here in sterile this difference
was not significant this difference was
so we were again surprised by this so we
decided to do it a third time
now what this graph is is it's the
37-degree from the first experiment so
you've already seen this data and the
37-degree natural without toxin added
also adding the toxin as you can see
from the Phet the features of the same
had no effect at all all right so this
is from the previous graph and then we
did it a third time with another
independent set of isolates and we got
the same pattern and across all of these
we again see a significant difference
between athletics genetic and
non-athletic so genetic isolates with
the non-athlete oxygenic isolates having
higher fitness so to summarize
genetic isolates have a fitness cost
instead of the hypothesized Fitness
benefit and this is seems to only occur
in natural soils at least we only got
significant differences in natural soils
and the addition of aflatoxin to the
soils had no effect at all so as we were
really surprised by this we had to ask
why is aflatoxin so costly to produce in
soils well the first piece of the puzzle
what we did was we added aflatoxin to
soils and then we measured it over time
and what you can see is that so here you
have the dotted lines are sterile soils
and the solid lines are non natural
soils at three different temperatures
and what you can see is even in the
dotted sterile conditions aflatoxins
degrade at a really high rate so it goes
from about 2,000 parts per million
athlete oxen in the soil to even a a
little over a thousand in just about
four days so this is degrading apple
toxin really quickly in fact we think
that this might be such quick
degradation that is difficult for the
fungus to produce enough toxin to keep
up with the rate at which it's degraded
in soil okay so this starts to paint a
picture of maybe why alpha toxin is not
a great thing not great for fitness in a
soil environment next we wanted to look
at the impact on microbial composition
so these are n MDS plots essentially I
don't want to get into it too much but
it's a multivariate analysis to look at
the community structure and what I want
you to see here is that we have so we
have added toxin and then we have the
producing ability of the fungus so added
toxin circle's is no edit ox in
triangles is added toxin and then with
blue and green I forgot this so the
fungus is green but it produces a toxin
that fluoresce is blue so throughout the
presentation when there's blue its
aflatoxin genic when it's green it's not
producing the toxin that fluoresce is
blue so it's not aflatoxin jenner so
Green is not producing it by itself blue
is and what you can see is that these
points are just all on top of each other
there's no clear pattern it's not like
you get the producers going
this way and the non producers going
over this way and again this is the
fungal community and the bacterial
community is even more so just
completely on top of each other so this
is kind of a visualization of the fact
that we found no significant difference
either with the addition of Atholl toxin
or with the ability of to produce alpha
toxin of the fungus itself on bacterial
community or sorry on microbial
communities now remember we had that we
had a specific idea that maybe bacillus
would be the answer to our questions of
why aflatoxin might confer a benefit
which it doesn't in soil and bear a
fireman so what this is is it's
demonstrating the log to base twofold
chain so these are actually small
changes across all of the different
phyla of bacteria that we found and each
spot here is an OT u which for practical
purpose you can think of as a species
essentially so within each one of these
each dot represents a species of this
phylum and then how much it changed from
go its abundance from not having an
aflatoxin producer so a non-athlete
oxygen and iceland to having an
athlete's oxygen and isolate so how much
did it change in that what we find is
that here in the Firmicutes which is
where bacillus is there's no significant
difference between the prevalence of
bacillus in microcosms inoculated with a
father that produces alpha toxin and
those in non-athlete oxygenic microcosms
in fact we didn't find any species
fungal or bacterial that changed
significantly between any of our
treatments so it really seems that after
the addition of alpha toxin and the
alpha toxin producing ability has very
little effect on soil microbes so again
we found instead of finding a Fitness
benefit to alpha toxin production we
found a Fitness cost remember at the
beginning I was saying for balancing
selection to be maintained
you need the non-athlete oxygen x to be
favored under some conditions and the
athlete oxygen X to be favored under
others so here we're creating an
environment in the soil when competing
with microbes we're not producing the
toxin confers a benefit essentially and
this may be because alpha toxin doesn't
seem to have much effect in the soil
environment it doesn't it's degraded
quickly as I showed you and it doesn't
seem to change the microbial community
composition and so as I mentioned
earlier the most likely explanation for
this is that in the soil environment
that is low in nutrients and they're
competing with other microbes the cost
the metabolic cost of producing
aflatoxin may result in a fitness loss
so this is the simplest explanation for
why this is happening why there'd be the
benefit to the eye slits that don't
produce the toxin okay so our first
hypothesis was about soil microbes we
did not find a benefit we found a cost
we decided to try again maybe it'll have
a benefit in the presence of insects so
insects have an own association with
Aspergillus flavus when there's insect
infestations in the field it creates
openings where Astralis clubs can get in
and infect in the field also in stored
grain environments it's known that the
that insects like maize weevils can
vector it it can go through their system
it can go come out in their Fras the
spores survive that is and so as a
result of this their insects are often
associated with increased athletics and
contamination and interestingly
aflatoxin is toxic to a large number of
invertebrates in vitro but none of these
studies that have added aflatoxins to
food have looked at what effect it has
on fungal fitness so they've just been
poisoning insects and invertebrates and
this photo to show you to kind of depict
that anytime I go out for a walk in the
woods I always see some kind of
invertebrate
on a mushroom when I come across it
there seems to be a lot of this kind of
interaction where invertebrates are
trying to eat fungi so we decided to
look at whether or not alpha toxin
production through interference
competition would allow it to claim the
resources that we give it better than
its non-athlete oxygenic counterparts so
similarly I'm going to start off with
telling you the methods here we use
little micro centrifuge tubes we put a
little bit of food in the bottom of it
that both Drosophila larvae and the
fungus could eat into the food we either
did or did not add aflatoxins similar to
the last time and then we added we did
or did not add larvae so to a single
micro centrifuge tube we'd add up to
nine larvae then we either added an
a-star genacore namitha toxigenic
isolate very similar construction to the
last set of experiments and extracted
DNA using qPCR as proxy for fitness
again and HPLC to quantify alpha toxins
so give you a sense of what this it
looks like here's the micro centrifuge
tube way zoomed in here's the food at
the bottom and what you can see here the
green is the fungus as you will remember
and here on the sides are some
Drosophila larvae that have started to
pupate and then here in the middle this
kind of white structure is a Drosophila
larvae that did not fare so well it
seems to have mostly died there didn't
make it to be patient so the first thing
that we need to figure out is is
aflatoxin toxic to our model organism so
over the course of 20 days we grew we
raised Drosophila larvae on food
containing increasing amounts of alpha
toxin content or aflatoxin and then we
looked at the number of Drosophila
larvae that Pugh pated and then the
number that emerged as adults and the
takeaway from this is yes as a photonic
entrer ssin increases the number that
pupate and the number that emerges as
adults goes way down so alpha toxin is
toxic to our model organism but again
this is just poisoning insects this
doesn't tell us
anything about the fungus and what we
want to know about whether or not this
confers a Fatah and confers an advantage
just to bring home that it's toxic here
are just awful larvae in our model
systems here and here and here you can
see the mouth parts but these black dots
in the middle are an immune response so
it's the melon ization that's either due
to a direct response to aflatoxin or
tissue damage caused by alpha toxin that
then elicits an immune response so it
really is toxic to our model organism in
case you were not convinced this is now
four days the last one was twenty days
which is why when we don't add the
fungus we see we don't see the drop-off
in number of living larvae so a number
of living larvae over alpha toxin
concentrations before what we saw over
twenty days it dropped off dramatically
here in four days they survived there
you can tell in the tubes that they're
not as happy but they don't die within
that span of time unless the fungus is
present so here we inoculated
non-athlete oxygenic which is green and
aphid oxygenic blue and you can see that
without any added toxin to the food
there's a significant difference in how
many larvae survive the living in the
tube with the fungus with the alpha
toxigenic killing more of the larvae
than the non matha toxigenic and as you
might expect as you add aflatoxin to the
tube the benefit of alpha toxin
decreases and they become more similar
because now there's a photogs in both of
these tubes where here there was no
aflatoxin at all before okay
so again this tells us nothing about our
main hypothesis this just shows that
when grown with the fungus larvae die so
if we got into the fungus here is the
fitness of the fungus as measured by
qpcr over increasing alpha toxin
concentrations and we have tubes that
have larvae and tubes that do not have
larvae so the tubes that do not have
larvae seems to have no change in fact
there's no snow change statistically
across the increasing alpha toxin
concentrate
so just adding alpha toxin to the tube
does not increase fitness of the fungus
however in the presence of larvae you
can see with the 9 larva competing with
the fungus it's there's a dramatic
reduction in fungal biomass compared to
no larvae and this is ameliorated and
becomes as the app toxin concentration
increases in fact these last two points
here at about 1.7 parts per million are
not significantly different whereas
these two are about 20 times different
so adding athlete's oxen to the medium
clearly increases fungal fitness however
we're interested in if the fungus is
production of alpha toxin can benefit it
and here the alpha toxigenic and
non-athletic genetic isolates were not
significantly different you can even
kind of see that they're just on top of
each other throughout this experiment
and to kind of visualize what this
difference looks like here's a tube with
no added aflatoxin and you can see a
bunch of the white food shining through
here's 1.75 parts per million alpha
toxin added to the food and this lush
green yellow Matt is Aspergillus flavus
Canady ating all over the surface the
larvae have all died more or less so
before we were adding toxin to the tubes
we wanted to ask does the natural
production by the fungus itself have an
effect so here we just did non-athlete
oxygenic and athletics genetic isolates
without alpha toxin added to the food
and what we see is no significant
difference between their growth when no
larvae are present but in the presence
of larvae we do see a significant
difference with alpha toxin genic
isolates having slightly higher Fitness
than non-athletes oxygenic isolates this
is a little bit shocking we went from
having this kind of visualizable
difference 20 fold difference just kind
of eking out a difference there and so
we had to ask why why is the difference
so small and what we have to
is that Aspergillus flavus doesn't just
produce aflatoxin it also produces a
bunch of toxic compounds like kojic acid
cyclopia zonic acid and alpha trem all
of which are known to be toxic to
insects you have to remember that both
the non atha toxigenic
and alpha toxigenic isolates may be
producing these compounds as well also
the amount of aflatoxin that are
isolates produced varied a thousandfold
from eight parts per billion to eight
parts per million so caught up in this
difference is a lot of the variation
between isolates and what compounds
they're producing and even how much
aflatoxin our alpha toxigenic isolates
are produced for context eight parts per
billion you could eat a corn that was
infected with that level in the u.s. not
in europe but in the u.s. that's
regulated at 20 parts per billion okay
so there is a significant effect a much
smaller effect on fitness of producing
aflatoxin of the fungus producing alpha
Sox in in the microcosms so what is
going on in these microcosms we we said
that this was an interference
competition hypothesis by which it would
claim resources and what I'm going to
show you here is there's a Drosophila
larvae here you can see its mouth parts
the little black parts there and up here
we have expert village committee of four
is coming off you can see that it
reaches up to the Canadian for and bites
it I'm gonna play it twice more really
gets its back into it so what this tells
us is that this competition isn't just
competition there's also fun jewelry
going on so it might be an interference
competition a story but there might also
be an anti fun jibbery
story going on here we didn't wind up
separating those in fact we kind of
think that when the fungus is growing
through a substrate it might be
inextricable you can't you can't
separate what's fun jibbery and what's
competition for resources because the
fungus has grown through all the
source but what this does show us is
that there's a direct eating of the
fungus which got us interested in what
effect that might have on the fungus and
we were surprised to see that with
larvae present isolates produced on
average so this is aflatoxin production
no larvae added to the tubes larvae
added to the tubes and simulated damage
so what I did was I took a toothpick
twice a day for four days and stabbed
each tube 30 times to simulate the kind
of little mouth parts that Drosophila
larvae would be eating the fungus web
and so in with no larvae they produce a
baseline amount of mass collection with
a single larva piece if I added nine
larvae it decreased the biomass so much
that was really difficult to compare
between things with a single larva it
increases alpha toxin and when I stab it
with the toothpick it really does not
like that and what this shows us is that
this is consistent with an induced
resistance response that it's no it
knows that it's being eaten so it
produces half toxins to defend itself
now it's important to note that because
it also does this just when I stab it
with a toothpick just when it's
physically damaged not only when the
larvae does it it's not clear that this
is necessarily an evolved adaptive
response this could just be that when I
damage it it releases oxidative stress
oxidative stress is known to increase
alpha toxin production and so this could
just be that when you damage it it
produces more alpha toxin
not that it's an evolved relationship
between the two okay so to summarize as
we started out with a Patuxent is toxic
to our model organisms aflatoxin when
added to the medium dramatically
increases alpha toxin the fitness of
Aspergillus flavus
but this is true for both talks and
nontox it just shows us that increases
fungal fitness in the presence of
insects but not in their absence and
then we showed that the production of
alpha toxin by the fungus itself with us
without us adding it also increases
fungal fitness but if you recall it was
just a little bit it wasn't nearly as
much
and then finally the graph that I was
just showing you aflatoxin production is
increased when fungus is physically
damaged consistent with an induced
resistance response so with insects
balancing selection could also be
maintained by the variability and how
susceptible insects are to it
so we tried similar experiments with
maize weevils and they were resistant to
alpha toxin up to 40 times the
concentration we used for Drosophila so
we just gave up at some point they just
they didn't care so you can imagine if
you're producing aflatoxin and there's a
resistant insect it might not confer the
benefit that it does if there's a
susceptible one and although we were
unable to show a fitness cost in the
second experiment we think that has to
do with the nutrient richness of the
medium rather than that there isn't a
cost to it so we saw it in the soils but
not here
so what does this mean for balancing
selection overall so if you have a piece
of organic matter on the soil surface
fungus comes the non-athletic so genic
isolates will do better so non-athletic
so genic are favored when competing with
soil microbes for resources when
competing with insects however the
production of aflatoxin benefits and
aflatoxin genic individuals are favored
when you have everything going on all at
once we have no idea it really depends
on how strong these factors are in the
field and so this does not preclude
áthis oxen from having other functions
in other systems and it needs to be
field tested so that's what I mean by we
don't know what the strength relative
strength of these factors are so if
there's both insects and soil microbes
present what's going on and we've
emphasized the potential for insects to
insect control to be good for alpha
toxin reductions because while it was
known that insects vectored Aspergillus
flavus before it was not known that they
could actually increase the amount of
toxin that as individual would produce
and most importantly for our questions
this presents a conceptual framework
that could explain what maintains
balancing selection for athletics and
production in Asheboro swallows and with
that
I'd like to thank all the people who
helped us collect soil with him we
couldn't have gotten the isolates my
committee members Brian Lazaro and Eric
Nelson funding from USD a free and my
lab members and other collaborators on
these projects and with that I would so
the question was what are the molecular
underpinnings of being able to produce
alpha toxin who are not being able to
produce aflatoxin and what effect that
might have so baphu toxin gene cluster
is composed of 25 genes and the way is
that non-athlete oxygen acai so let's be
calm non-athletic genic varies a lot
there's some consistency but it can go
from a single nucleotide polymorphism to
missing the entire cluster and just
about everything in between as to what
effect missing having many of the genes
versus missing the whole cluster has on
fitness we don't know we just we've just
found out that producing the toxin
versus not has this effect is a little
unclear if there's a difference between
retaining some of the genes or not in
the cluster and two strains that are
genetically different one can produce
and one cannot so none of these
experiments were was oh sorry the
question was if we're comparing one ask
toxigenic and one non-athletic one atha
toxigenic one non-athletic genic how do
we get at the diversity that might
underpin differences between the two
groups in the field and so the answer to
that is that we've so we've sampled
field isolates and
these experiments we've used more than
one isolate so each experiment I think
had a minimum of four or five of each
type of isolate in it so we hope with
that that we've captured some of the
diversity and seen that much more stable
in the food substrate it is in soil even
sterile so do you have any explanation
so the question was why might aflatoxin
be more stable in food than in soil and
I don't have a great answer for that
soils or soils a really nasty place I
mean it's known that humic acids and
things and all of the compounds that are
present in soils they get really
difficult for compounds to persist there
but I don't know specifically what could
be happening compared to in foods well
could be but it was even in the sterile
soils so you have to exercise special
techniques to protect yourself and
others in the lab yeah we followed we
use a biosafety cabinet when working
with the fungus we use gloves the real
issue with atha toxin is when it's
ingested so I was able to refrain from
eating any contaminated substances but
but we still were careful with it
working with it in biosafety cabinet and
using gloves whenever use being pure
alpha toxin somebody did maybe it was
Cornell I don't get you nested they've
been all over us to come in contact with
specialists would have evolved some
resistance compared to the Drosophila
larvae or anything just
so it was it was the the maize weevil
but yeah so the question is might
insects as that are more likely to
interact with estrogens in the field
more likely to be resistant to athlete's
oxen and I wouldn't be surprised if that
were the case there's a seems to be a
lot of variation in how susceptible they
are I know that the corn corn armyworm
is susceptible to aflatoxin within the
range that we were looking at with
Drosophila and there are a few other
agriculturally relevant organisms that
are susceptible as aflatoxin within the
range that we looked at but they haven't
been done with the fungus there so we
don't know yet this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu